also ich glaube wir sind schon ein land
das sehr gut aufgestelltes finanziell
und auch viel abfedern kann
und mein eindruck ist ja auch was ich
auf in vielen interviews dann gelesen
habe
flüchtlinge die sich dann auch hier so
ein bisschen etabliert haben über eine
gewisse jahre vielleicht zwei drei vier
fünf jahren jetzt in der letzten zeit
hier geblieben sind eine ausbildung
vielleicht auch genossen haben die
wollen ja auch nicht alle in deutschland
bleiben also ich glaube diese angst dass
wir jetzt so überrannt werden von alten
oder so die wollen dann auch wieder
vielleicht in andere länder weiter oder
in ihr heimatland zurück sofern es jetzt
nicht sehr krisengeschüttelt nach wie
vor ist und so also von daher glaube ich
sind wir da gut aufgestellt in
deutschland wirklich humanitäre hilfe
also leisten zu können und auch einfach
aufnehmen zu können da bin ich voll
überzeugt fordern würdest bei den
politikern oder gibt es irgendwas wo du
sagst das fände ich gut wenn ihr das
machen würden also eine forderung
stellen
also ich würde rand ist wenn ich könnte
würde ich jetzt auch wie patricia es
auch gesagt wirklich aktuell einfach
sagen jetzt muss gehandelt werden und
die kinder die ihr glücklich wenn man
diese bilder sieht also kinder einfach
auf zu nehmen jugendliche die eltern
natürlich irgendwie dazu sofern sie
überhaupt gemeinsam auch geflohen sind
und sich in dem lager befinden einfach
wirklich konkret jetzt den aufruf holt
die hierher
[Musik]